I am joined
by Albert Chen and he is an evolutionary
biologist he's a paleontologist he has
been studying birds so modern Birds and
the evolution of birds and the fossil
record so
Albert welcome
hello it's a pleasure to be here yeah
and uh you are also an artist and you've
done this amazing poster that we're
going to be looking at here quite a bit
today
and I yeah I'm very excited for this
conversation we're going to talk about
why it is that uh Birds survived while
uh you know the dinosaurs went the way
of the dinosaurs I mean well technically
birds are dinosaurs but you know yeah
they're dinosaurs you know what I mean
yes yeah so
uh let's just start by talking about
about yourself so you've got so you've
got quite the online presence a lot of
people know you from your art and yeah
kind of yeah yeah
and then I yeah you've
you've done some speaking at uh the Tet
zukon yes there's some videos of you
online doing some speeches there but
yeah tell us about how you got into your
line of research yeah sure uh so I would
say in terms of my interest in the
subject of evolutionary biology uh
that's probably something that goes
about as far back as I can remember I've
always been interested in animals I've
always been interested in Natural
History so how animals live and how they
came to be and so I think as long as
I've had a sense of what biological
evolution is this is something I've been
interested in
um
uh in terms of bird Evolution
specifically
I think
um
probably when I became really interested
in it would have been in
the I would say early 2000s or so yeah
um and it was around that time when I
started becoming more aware of many of
the recent paleontological discoveries
related to bird Evolution
um notably the increasing fossil fines
of Mesozoic dinosaurs that were not
Birds preserved with feathers and
and I think that you know in many ways
scientifically that was sort of the
final nail in the coffin for uh you know
to kind of seal the deal on birds being
dinosaurs
um and like that was fascinating to me
yeah like not only the fact that uh well
the dinosaurs actually are extinct
because there's this really diverse and
really common group of organisms alive
today that are still
um that they're still represented by uh
but I think that also made me more
interested in uh kind of birds
themselves he was like oh wow they're
they're the Living Branch of dinosaurs
uh so
like uh I think it was it was from the
non that I became really interested in
bird Evolution yeah
um
yeah
and eventually uh I think
I think at the time uh when I was little
like I didn't necessarily
think that uh oh I I wanted I want to do
research on on the subject but in
hindsight it feels like that probably
was like the way I was gonna go anyways
um so it was uh it was a pretty natural
kind of uh progression I suppose uh when
I when I went to college I studied
geology and focused on taking classes in
paleontology
um and you know constantly paid
attention to the scientific literature
in terms of the topics that I was
interested in
um and later on I did a a master's
degree at the University of Bristol in
their very large and uh very excellent
paleobiology program
um
and right when I was finishing up with
my Master's Degree I am
uh I got very lucky because my
supervisor Dr Daniel field or who or he
he would who would become my PhD
supervisor and had just started his own
lab and he was basically interested in
many of the same questions that I was
interested in the on the origins of
birds at their evolution and also their
interrelationships with each other so I
got in contact with him and applied for
a PhD with him and I got accepted so I
became one of his first PhD students at
the University of bath he now works at
the University of Cambridge so he got
that new position in the middle of my
PhD and
um now I am currently a junior research
fellow also at the University of
Cambridge and that is essentially a very
fancy post doctoral position
so yeah that's currently where I am now
yeah so so yeah you've been in the UK
for a while now yes yeah
so can you so we're looking at your
poster right now so aside from your
research you do this this art which I
love this stuff I mean I actually have a
copy of this poster on my wall which I
which I bought I got a huge huge version
of it uh can you zoom in on a little bit
you're it's kind of zoomed out right now
yes right yeah so right right now I'm
showing like the the full thing but uh
yes we can we can take a look at how it
looks close up
um so I guess maybe I'll start with the
close to the bottom so can can everybody
see that yeah so yeah that's coming
through nice now let me uh
do you want me to scroll through it yeah
yeah yeah just just yeah just start
scrolling through and um tell us just a
little bit so how long have you been
doing art I mean that's that's the other
thing that you've been doing for yeah uh
I I would say art is also something I've
been doing for a long time like it's
also like probably as long as I can
remember are very close to that I've
always liked drawing but um I'm not a
professionally trained uh artist in in
any way at all so
um
I would I would definitely not consider
myself a skilled artist or anything like
that but it's something I enjoy doing
and um since my uh my art style I kind
of tends towards a sort of cartoony and
simplistic I I think I love it it's yeah
it's it's kind of like uh well my so my
art style for stated clearly is was
largely inspired like early on I started
working with rosemary Moscow we actually
did that Yeah we actually did a video
together and uh like my art style is
kind of played off hers and I see a
little bit of that in in years as well
she's inspired all of us she's
definitely a major source of inspiration
for sure yeah
um and yeah so I think um I think our
style is like like these uh are pretty
they lend themselves pretty well to
creating sort of infographics I suppose
yeah and uh so that that's one of the
main uh types of art I make I guess is
informative uh simple but informative
graphics and uh of course since one of
my favorite subjects and the subject of
most of my own scientific research is
phylogenetics
um a lot of my artwork focuses on
phylogenetics is depicting The
evolutionary relationships between or
among different organisms so that's uh
this is an example of that yeah and and
this is so
we kind of want to start out by just
talking about phylogenetics right so you
have put together this tree for the
evolution of birds right
um and this is based on
well yeah tell us about tell us about
this tree that you've you've put
together here because there's been a lot
of I guess changing in the bird
evolutionary tree over the past maybe 15
years or so it seems and so yeah tell us
about that and just phylogenetics in
general yes a little little 101 course
yeah I could definitely give that a try
uh so uh phylogenetics is essentially
the study of how different organisms are
related to one another and by that we
mean which organisms share a more recent
common ancestor with each other and you
can think of this in terms of your own
family tree so for example you are more
closely related to your siblings than to
your cousins uh because you and your
siblings share a common ancestor in your
parents who are more recent common
ancestors in the common ancestor you
share with their cousins it would be
your grandparents
um for example and so if you trace back
far enough in the history of life
um as far as we know all life on Earth
shares a common ancestor with each other
and so we can reconstruct a phylogenetic
tree or the phylogenetic relationships
of any group of organisms on Earth
relative to one another yeah and
phylogeny is a kind of very important
for understanding the evolution of
organisms
um because knowing how organisms are
related to each other helps you kind of
reconstruct their evolutionary history
and kind of puts them in context of uh
like which groups they evolved from a
lot of the time in evolutionary biology
we have questions about why are certain
organisms like this and not like that
and a lot of the time the difference
comes down to phylogeny comes down to
evolutionary history what groups a
certain organism belongs to
um kind of influences how they evolve
and
and I personally like what uh why is it
really appealing to me about phylogeny
is just the fact that we can be
constructed for any group of organisms
on earth like you can you can get a
phylogeny uh showing your relationship
too like a palm tree and a cardinal and
uh E coli bacteria and uh you know and
it's it's true we are all related to
each other and so in a sense we all
shared this kind of kinship and I find
that really really fascinating
um
so yeah in terms of this particular tree
specifically in terms of bird phylogeny
uh so this poster I drew to depict of
course uh possibly my favorite subject
of all time and that is bird Evolution
uh I drew this uh poster while I was
writing up my PhD thesis which might not
have been the best idea but yeah it gave
me a lot of extra work that's for sure
but I'm pretty happy with how it came
out so there are definitely a number of
different
um kind of
uh very deliberate kind of features I
included in this phylogeny and first of
these is that um I did want to represent
all the major bird groups that are alive
today
um but I didn't want to restrict myself
only to that I also wanted to include uh
fossil groups of birds and all the um
groups that are extinct on this poster
are the groups that I have left without
colors so you can kind of distinguish
them quite readily
um so where possible where we have like
relatively well supported positions for
fossil groups or particularly
interesting fossil groups I tried to
include them in the tree and in addition
to sort of the modern group of birds I
also want to include their extinct
relatives as well so I also included on
the street many of the groups that are
more closely related to birds and to any
other living
organism but are now extinct so that
includes not only very bird-like forms
but also uh you know all of the non-brew
dinosaurs such as T-Rex and uh
Allosaurus and uh even with long neck
sauropods
um and things like the horned dinosaurs
and armored dinosaurs and all the rest
and so this goes back all the way to the
base of what we call like the total bird
lineage
um so everything that's more closely
related to birds into any other modern
form
um so that's uh kind of the the gist of
this Trio body yeah and yeah so uh you
asked like what kind of data is this
based on in the fact that our
understanding of bird phylogeny has
changed
um over the years especially in recent
times
um so when we study philology when we're
reconstructing these phylogenetic trees
there are multiple types of data that we
can use to try and figure this out and
of course traditionally the main way of
reconstructing phylogenetic trees has to
be has has been looking at morphology
and so that is like the overall anatomy
and appearance of uh organisms yeah and
that certainly um been the main way of
reconstructing phylogenes for a long
time and to an extent we still use it
um
however uh in recent times uh there has
been a shift at least when it comes to
uh studying the relationships of modern
organisms
um and now there's a there's been a
shift where people start using molecular
data instead and that can be data from
the proteins uh that organisms used to
build their bodies or uh their genetics
um
so uh because
when it comes to uh molecular kind of
analyzes we can often collect a lot more
data uh from the genetics and proteins
than we can from anatomy of these at
these in terms of how easy it is to get
this this data uh you can like sequence
a genome that's like
however thousands or millions of base
pairs long
um
for a modern organism whereas when we
study anatomy you have to you have to
actually like personally go and look at
these uh physical features and like take
notes on what they look like and compare
them by hand and uh that that just uh
isn't isn't quite as automated as
something like genetics can can do and
yeah you can actually just run software
over once you have the sequence you can
use software to just build the trees for
you versus yes yes
well yeah like and we also use software
to analyze morphological data too uh but
like there are differences there too for
example um because DNA basically only
comes in four different base pairs it's
a lot easier for us to model the
evolution of DNA over time compared to
something like morphology where a lot of
the observations are a lot more
qualitative and you know one feature
doesn't necessarily evolve in the same
way as another
um and so there are definitely some
major challenges to doing morphological
phylogenetics and that is a major reason
why
um uh mostly when we study the father
genetics of modern organisms we mostly
switch to using molecules and especially
genetics to do it
and so because of this genetics
Revolution uh we found that a lot of our
traditional understanding of how
organisms are related to each other
based on morphology
um has turned out to be probably
incorrect
um and I wouldn't say that's the case
all across the board there definitely
were uh there are definitely plenty of
relationships that we were able to
figure out prior to molecular
phylogenetics but nonetheless there are
some real surprises here uh after the
genetics Revolution and so our current
understanding of modern bird phylogeny
is primarily based on this genetic
information but uh yeah go ahead yeah
yeah so yeah my question here is we we
had had basic uh you know evolutionary
trees of life in general
uh that were produced even by people you
know Darwin was was messing around with
this sort of thing right right how
accurate overall so like if you look at
the the like tetrapods in general so
land animals with backbones yeah how
accurate was the their rough sketches
even from like Darwin's time compared to
now because I know that within Birds
there's a lot of details that have been
switched but in general were we very
accurate when we were just going by
Anatomy or were there just yeah major
errors okay right right uh
that I mean that that's a great question
I I guess a lot of it depends on a
case-by-case basis or like how How
Deeply or how detailed you're looking at
things but like I would say in
like for for vertebrates for example
like for backboned animals
um the very broad Strokes of the tree we
pretty much were right about uh so like
you know we we have things like uh the
Java's fishes are the uh sister group to
or you know this is the sister group
meaning the closest living relatives to
the rest of the living vertebrates
um we have and then the the sharks are
the sister of the rest of those uh
rayfin fishes on the sister group to the
rest of those uh we have a syracants and
lungfishes and uh the tetrapods of for
the invertebrates Are all uh part of the
lobe and uh blade of vertebrates
um and then we have amphibians being
Sister grouped to the rest of the
tetrapods the reptiles being the sister
group uh to the mammals
um and reptiles in this case including
birds so uh yeah I I think in terms of
very broad Strokes uh we were largely
correct when it comes to the vertebrate
Tree of Life uh just based on
morphological evidence
um but they're within the vertebrate
group of course there are many
individual cases that came up as
surprises and so some of the major some
of the most um uh like one of the
biggest surprises would have been the
position of turtles which to to this day
is still a quite controversial uh but
the genetic evidence is very strong that
they're closely related to the crocodile
and bird group uh which was not
necessarily what we predicted from
morphology
um and yeah there are things like that
and the the thing about a lot of um
about a lot of those surprises is that
uh turtles are really weird like a lot
of these are genetic surprises they they
kind of come out of groups that are very
morphologically strange and that we
don't necessarily have a very complete
kind of evolutionary
um sequence for them in the fossil
record and but we're starting to get
that with Turtles now with more and more
fossil fines and so uh people are
starting to to find evidence that oh
there actually are morphological
features that link the turtles to the
the crocodiles and Birds
um but yeah in a way we're kind of
playing ketchup uh with the genetics
data on on that front yeah well
I think it'd be helpful to talk real
quick about why uh why morphology
sometimes tricks us because we had this
we had this with whales as well I
remember there was a big surprise with
whales because there was there was a
link to Wales with uh I can't remember
there was a carnivore carnivorous that's
right yeah um the the messenger kids
were an extinct group of carnivorous
mammals yep yeah and their teeth were
similar and that's what they were going
off of and then there was this argument
there were arguments that that whales
were
um
uh
what do you call my RDO doctorodactyls
yeah even hooked mammals yeah right
there were arguments from morphology
from that too but they it was when the
genetics came out and that the
paleontologists were arguing with the
geneticists and and yeah there's there's
a little bit of drama I remember I was
talking to uh to one guy he's like yeah
when I finally admitted or when I
finally when I was finally convinced uh
with the the true relationship was he
said that he was so grumpy that he like
he wouldn't admit it for several months
right right because he had been arguing
the opposite thing he had a he'd even
set up a museum at his college where he
was arguing the opposite thing and so
right
but yeah so why
why do we why did morphology trick Us in
certain ways yes
yeah and there are a couple reasons but
uh like you know we have cases like with
the turtles or they're just so so weird
that they're difficult to place but uh
certainly a major reason is what we call
a convergent evolution
um and that is that uh different groups
of organisms that are distantly related
to each other can often evolve very
similar anatomical adaptations
um to uh you know because they they
function similarly or they are adapted
to similar Lifestyles
um and in fact uh since I have this on
the screen here a notable example in
Birds is the example of a Greaves and
runes
um yeah so here here's a group of birds
called the Grieves they're a group of
diving birds say they you know spend
most of their lives in water and uh
their main way of feeding is they dive
underwater using uh by kicking their
foot-propelled swimmers
um and they catch prey under the water
and they're very highly adapted to this
kind of locomotion
um and then there's a different group
called
balloons or if you're in in Britain you
call them the divers
um but they are also very similar in
that they primarily catch prey
underwater by kicking with their their
hind limbs
um and for a very long time we thought
that greeds and loons were closely
related but then the genetic data came
in and it turns out that they're not
they're actually very distant relatives
to one another
um where with the loons being more
closely related things like penguins and
albatrosses uh whereas the greeds it
turns out are more closely related to
flamingos so uh that that's definitely
one of the major examples in Birds now
um we have there's several different
types of webbed feet that exist yes
is do we think that the ancestral state
of
um of modern Birds was webbed foot or
was it uh
separated toes right that that's a good
question
um and I would say in general we don't
have enough data to say for sure uh
where whether the um the last common
ancestor of all modern Birds had webbed
feet or not
um if we look at the the base of modern
Birds
um the first split that happens in the
modern bird
um group is the split uh is this split
that where it gives rise to one lineage
that goes to uh the ostriches and emus
and cassowaries and Kiwis and a lot of
other flightless groups
um and those birds do not have what feet
right
um but then you go to the next Branch
out the one at least everybody else and
one of the first branches is one that
leads to uh the chickens and ducks in
their relatives and and well you know
Rich chicken like birds don't really
have a feeder though some of them do
have like a little bit of webbing
between their toes uh but the the duck
like group they they definitely do have
more feet
um and there is an argument to be made
that perhaps the last common ancestor of
modern Birds was something that was uh
at least feeding near the water or maybe
not necessarily in the water but feeding
on shorelines and things like that
um so I would say it's not completely
out of the question that the last common
event ancestor modern Birds was a
web-footed animal but I also would not
bet on it either yeah yeah that's
interesting so
all right what was
okay so I maybe maybe we've covered this
well enough but you got morphology
you've got molecules obviously with
fossils we only have morphology so for
most part
well have we been able to correct
ourselves then so so if we only have
morphology
what have we learned from genetics that
can tell us what types of morphological
traits are best for building phylogenies
because as you said convergent evolution
can can confuse us so are there are
there certain types of traits that
that actually do give us an honest take
on the phylogeny yeah that that's a
great question and uh the short answer
is it depends and uh this is actually
um a field that's very much still in
progress you could say and in fact is a
lot of what my own research focuses on
is uh using the our genetic
understanding of modern Brew
phylogenetics uh to try and figure out
which uh features are actually the most
reliable in birds for reconstructing the
phylogenic relationships and for for my
own research a lot about it is still a
work in progress so
um I I actually worked on
um this particular topic focusing on the
uh the shoulder girdle and four limb
bones of birds for part of my PhD and
that work still has not been published
yet so I I don't want to go into too
much detail
um and but uh but yeah the short answer
is yes there there probably are
morphological features that we can use
uh to reconstruct follow Jag
relationships accurately and potentially
there may also be analytical methods
that we can use to improve our
morphological phylogenetics or the
accuracy or morphological phylogenetics
but um yeah a lot of that is still is
still something that's very much
um in the progress of being worked on
um so uh obviously being able to improve
our the activism our morphological
phylogenetics will help in interpreting
fossils and so that that is a big part
of what I'm interested in in terms of my
own research yeah yeah and it's it's
just so interesting
because you have to when you're looking
at traits only you have to that gets
filtered through a person's brain
exactly then gets put into the computer
and then the computer can can use a you
know use the same
you know right process to analyze
everyone's data but yeah it has to
filter through a person's eyes and brain
first and that's a big uh that's just a
big problem for getting you know
everyone's going to see things a little
bit differently yes for sure trying to
real trying to figure out like what what
actually matters is it the length of
this bone compared to that bone it's
going to give us important data versus
it just just depends on how
like what parts of the body can evolve
fastest because I guess I guess you
don't really want well
it depends on what what resolution
you're wanting for
for
your your tree I suppose but you're
going to want slow evolving things for
distant relationships you're going to
want maybe fast revolving traits for
uh shorter distances to so yeah it's a
really complicated problem very much
yeah
so yeah that that's well yes good luck
on trying to figure out how to do that
yes thank you yes I I think we'll need
it
um but uh yeah definitely there has been
progress made in recent years and yeah
there are they're at the increasing you
know numbers of studies and and uh types
of research methods that are being used
to try and reconcile
um kind of our new wonders genetic space
understanding with uh what kind of
information we can extract from the
fossils and so uh yeah I guess so just
to just to briefly mention this
um in terms of like what studies are
based this particular poster on are
obviously there's no single study that
covers absolutely every single one of
the animals I drew on this poster
because there's a mixture of living
forms of the mixture of fossil forms and
uh some of these are in the grand scheme
of things quite distantly related to
each other
um so like a study that's being done on
one particular group is going to cover
others so this this poster is based on a
sort of amalgamation of many many
different studies
um in terms of the relationships between
the modern groups uh they are primarily
based on recent genetic studies of birds
and there have been many large-scale
genetic studies that try to figure out
how all the birds in the world are
related or well well maybe not literally
like all the species but like all the
major groups how they're related
um and so I tried to base the phylogeny
on those
um but when it comes to the fossils like
you have to use morphological studies
the morphological results of
morphological analyzes
um to to get um to get the positions of
most of those there are actually some
recent extinctions that we have uh
genetic information for such as the the
Moa New Zealand and elephant Birds uh
Madagascar they they are very recent
Extinction that died out in historical
times so we actually have genetic data
from those and they have come out in
some pretty surprising positions like
the maligasy elephant versus being
closer to New Zealand kiwi and MOA that
are also from New Zealand actually being
close to a flying group called The
tinomous are now found in South America
um wow but uh for most part yeah the uh
the positions of fossil taxa they are
based on morphological studies here but
um like when it comes to birds like like
groups within the modern bird radiation
um
I've tried to follow studies that take
into account the genetic results so um a
lot of the time what we do when we uh
when we have uh when we're studying
fossil members of living groups is that
where we actually constrain the analysis
to only recover the relationships that
we know from genetics
um and then uh based on that framework
we then add the anatomical data in and
uh try to resolve the positions of
fossil attacks are in the most likely
um placement based on based on that
framework so
uh I try to where possible I try to like
place the fossil attack stuff
um in positions that are consistent with
studies like that yeah now so when we're
trying to correct now that we have now
that we have genetics it's so so much
easier to just analyze basically it's
like
comparing two books to each other right
um versus trying to look at all these
different anatomical differences when
we're trying to correct how we look at
Anatomy based on uh genetic data is this
really
um group specific so what we learn in
Birds is not going to be applicable to
mammals we have to do this yeah
completely differently for mammals it
can be yes
um there there have been a number of
recent studies that have come out
looking at like how reliable
um different morphological traits of
different parts of the body are
informative for phylogenetics of
different groups of organisms yeah
um and so for example there was a recent
study that came out well I said reason
but within the last few years
um that came out saying that uh mammal
teeth are actually not so informative
for their phylogeny yeah which is a bit
of a problem for paleontologists because
a lot of the time with mammal fossils
especially with the small bodied ones uh
the majority of fossils that we find are
teeth so right but you know that's
something that's good to know right
um yeah and it's also something that
makes a lot of sense because right teeth
are the tools that things use to survive
and so they're going to be evolving
rapidly I mean as as diet shifts teeth
are going to change quickly and so you
can exactly you can get uh
you can get reruns happening you can get
a lot of convergent evolution happening
with teeth right
yeah and uh there I've also been studies
like trying to compare the anatomy of
different groups
um and how reliable they are relative to
the molecular trees and so I think
they're actually with one recent study
that
um found that actually uh I think
compared to compared to mammals birds
don't have it so bad when it comes to
anatomical characters so that there's
some hope there
um so uh yeah like
yeah it definitely varies from group to
group yeah yeah that's really cool
big surprises in Birds I I used to have
a parrot so maybe we should talk about
parrots because that's uh that was the
biggest surprise that I I have seen in a
while yes
uh so yeah I I would agree that that
definitely was one of the biggest
surprises in kind of the recent uh uh
bird phylogenies
um so and that that is the fact that uh
parrots are actually more closely
related to Falcons than say uh something
like a hawk or ego would be yeah so
Falcons are closer relatives to parrots
than the Hawks which are something
that's pretty unexpected because uh for
most part there were people who
suspected otherwise but for most part uh
for most of them are uh for most
important theological history has been
assumed that uh Falcons and Hawks formed
a group they were both the birds of prey
that are active during the day and they
have very similar adaptations in many
regards
um but yeah this genetic data came out
and turns out that yeah actually Falcons
are more closely related to the parrots
and not only is the Paris but also to
the uh the songbirds
um and then they are the Hawks
um which is a yeah it it was it was big
um and I remember when the when the one
of the first studies that found this
result came out and I think uh in 2008 I
even saw comments from some of the
authors on that paper and they were like
yeah that's really strange we're
actually not too sure that that's
actually correct
um but since then many other Studies
have been done on uh you know bird
phylogeny and very consistently we find
these results that Falcons and periods
are closely related like no matter what
you know the types of genes you you
sequence or uh the data set that they
use or who analyze the data center what
methods he used it this is a very
strongly supported relationship
um so we are pretty confident now that
this is most likely correct
um and yeah I would add that uh we we've
been um you know we found that uh
morphological uh phylogenetics can uh
can be very misleading but uh I would
say that um like genetics is not immune
to the problems that morphology can have
like right we know convergent evolution
happens with genetics too uh it's just
that it has the benefit of first of all
we can produce a lot more data or are
these produce it a lot more easily and
also we we can model uh genetics
Evolution uh more easily than we can
with morphology like I mentioned earlier
uh and that that's those are probably
like the major reasons that um genetic
phylogenetics uh tends to be considered
more reliable nowadays
um but uh but yeah so this is a this is
now a very very surprising relationship
um yeah and well it yeah it just seems
like with genetics the the amount of
convergence that could be expected as
far smaller because I mean especially if
you're looking at individual nucleotides
I mean they're just it just becomes
there's no way that if there's you know
a thousand mutations different there's
no way that you're gonna confuse that
but there are some there are some types
of mutations like uh chromosome
rearrangements and so on that can be
fairly confusing to try and follow when
you're trying to follow the evolutionary
history of things right yeah absolutely
yeah
um and so obviously like this newfound
relationship has had implications for
how we um interpret the evolution and
origins of these groups of birds
um and so this is actually actually an
example I think where we have a sort of
reciprocal illumination between fossils
and uh genetics
um
so well with this newfound understanding
of you know how these different groups
of birds of prey are related to each
other uh there are a couple of different
possibilities
um
for how this kind of arrangement came to
be right so we have the uh the Falcons
and the Hawks and Eagles being quite
distant from each other so uh one
possibility is that they evolved their
vertebrate their raptorial features
convergently and so they completely
independently developed features related
to hunting other backbone animals um so
that's certainly a possibility
um but something else to keep in mind is
that these two are not the only groups
of birds of prey out there right so
they're also the owls which are a
nocturnal group of birds yeah and um the
position of Albus has been historically
quite controversial like are they
closely related to the other birds of
prey or not uh well the genetics
um data seem to show that they are more
closely related to the Hawks and Eagles
into Falcons
um there's still a bit of um uncertainty
when it comes to how they're related to
some of the other members of this
lineage but like for the purposes of of
this discussion they're they're closer
to the Hawks and Eagles than to the
Falcons and then we have this group over
here so this group called the Serie Amos
uh they live in South America today and
there are only two living species uh
probably their main claim to fame is
that they're closely related to the
extinct Terror Birds which were apex
predators
um in South America and also a little
bit in North America too um these are
these are gigantic birds that were they
grew up to over two meters long
um and then two meters tall I should say
um
yeah and uh the Serie A Mess are much
smaller but they they are still a
carnivorous um Birds uh well technically
they're omnivorescent they're also eat
some some plant material but uh for the
most the majority of their diet consists
of smaller animals and um they mostly
like hunt stalking like uh open areas on
their long legs and they grab things
with their feet throw it against the
ground to kill it and then they're able
to pin down their prey with like this
specialized Claw on their foot
um to and rip them apart while they're
doing that
um yeah and so we have the yeah are
those the ones that throw they they'll
they'll pick up a lizard and smash it
against the ground too or yeah okay yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they'll also do
it with eggs as well to break them which
is kind of funny because you have these
videos of them like throwing golf balls
again probably because they think
they're eggs or something yeah yeah
that's hilarious because they just
bounce it's yes they're like oh that's a
strange right
um so so yeah we have like these four
different uh groups of raptorial birds
um and they all seem to be distantly
related to each other that is they don't
form an exclusive group like there's no
bird of prey lineage in this assemblage
um
however
um they do all belong to one particular
group of birds called Keller 80s which
translates to the land Birds
um so this is a group that does not
include all birds that live on land but
includes a vast majority of them and
specifically it actually includes like a
lot of the birds that live in trees
um so in addition to the different
groups of birds of prey it also includes
things like oh the Kingfishers or
woodpeckers and of course like we
mentioned earlier the parrots and the
songbirds
um and if you trace back like the
distribution of the raptorial lifestyle
uh Chile base of calorie these you get a
sort of a different
um a sort of alternative explanation for
when that raptoriality evolved in this
group because there's also a possibility
that maybe the last common ancestor of
teller Avis was actually a bird of prey
and so it this lifestyle is retained in
the owls the Hawks and Eagles the
Falcons and the Serie Amos and then lost
in things like the parrots and songbirds
for example yeah um that is another
possibility so which one is correct yeah
that is very hard to say looking at only
living organisms but the fossils might
give us a clue and so there are actually
a couple of groups of fossil Birds
notably like this one called the
mesolaterids
um which seem to have been possibly
raptorial they had hooked beaks they had
pretty big claws on their feet
um but in many of their features uh we
think they're they might actually be
more closely related to parrots and
songbirds than to the Falcons or
sarriimas or any of the other vertebrate
groups
um so if this is the case then this then
support to the idea that parrots and
songbirds evolved from a raptorial
ancestor
um and from there you can trace back you
know you know by extension that the last
common ancestor until the 80s uh might
have been a raptorial bird
um yeah okay so yeah so this is this is
a case where knowing something about the
genetics helped us place the position of
the fossils and knowing something about
the fossils helps us understand the
evolution of the living forms in the
context of their current
um currently understood phylogenetic
tree
um so that's quite an interesting
example I would say yeah I yeah I would
say well you know it was interesting
living with I had my I had a son con
your parrot Apollo his name was Apollo I
had him for
oh probably nine years
and uh
the the really interesting thing about
him was I was very surprised that he
loved eating meat he would steal meat
whenever I was eating meat he would
steal it off my plate and he'd just go
he'd fly I thought he was going to get
sick you know right like and then I
would read about online like no birds
eat a lot of or parrots eat a lot of
insects they eat a lot of uh and they
will still meet they'll
um yeah sometimes they'll eat baby birds
from other species it's like okay
but but they do have very weak Talons
compared to a falcon so that's uh that's
a really interesting
you know if they are related to Falcons
it's interesting that the diet is
Switched and the the strength and the
talons has has changed so much uh we
also have the parrots have very unique
pigments uh yes do we find any of those
in Falcons that are unique to that
lineage our Falcons did all the unique
pigments and parrots evolve afterward
yeah as far as I'm aware we don't find
any of those pigments it Falcons or or
in songbirds for that matter so uh by
our current understanding
um is likely that those pigments evolved
in the Paris lineage yep so yeah the
bright the bright yellow and the bright
uh the bright red yeah and then they're
they're greens and their Blues are
iridescent or it's the structural yeah
yeah
that's that's really interesting
um
uh
I'm trying to think what we well is
there anything else you want to talk
about with with phylogeny and actually
uh ladies and gentlemen you can you can
ask questions in the in the comments
section here we've got some
have you talked about
I don't know how to is it strikes or
shrieks oh shrikes yes
um I'm getting a question have you
talked about strikes yet uh no we
haven't mentioned them yet well let's
talk about strikes sure okay so the
strikes are actually a group of songberg
um and but they're a pretty unusual
group so in the philology they're all
the way up here
um so they're kind of close to related
crows and Jace
um but they're in a digital group of
songbirds in that they uh actually have
this kind of raptorial habits so uh
they're kind of Infamous for us
um you can see as I've drawn here they
have a bit of a hooked beak they mostly
eat meat and uh so they'll actually go
and Hunt other small animals and not
just insects but like other backbone
animals um even things like smaller
birds and small mammals such as mice and
such even though these are not
particularly big birds like you know
even a relatively big strike is the size
of your uh like American robin or
something like that yeah they're not
huge
um but they're very effective predators
and they can kill quite large prey
relative to their body size and one of
their most infamous types of behaviors
is that they will actually impale the
prey that they have caught on sharp
objects such as thorns and branches
um and uh there are a couple of a couple
of reasons for this so one of these is
to store food for later so just like
keep this whole larger like I could get
animals in a bush or a scrub or
something like that
um
uh and for another it's because
um shrike's uh being songbirds they do
not have like the strong Talons of some
something like a hawk or a falcon would
have
um so it helps for them to like be able
to Anchor their prey onto something
while they rip it apart with that hooked
beak
um and since their feet are not as
suited for doing this though they were
used like this impalement Behavior to
kind of uh serve in that function
instead
um yeah so they're a fascinating group
but they they are definitely not closely
related to the uh the major kind of bird
of prey groups that we discussed earlier
um they we are very confident that they
are a member of the Songbird lineage so
they might be an example of songbird's
guy re-evolving uh raptorial habits
right well the other interesting thing
about them it seems it seems like a
really bad idea to just leave the food
out it's going to get stolen
are they guarding it after they after
they hang their food like how that's
question because I I watch
I watch crows steal from Hawks all the
time right just and I'll see it walking
around outside you'll it happens so
often that without being much of a
birder I've seen that happen multiple
times
yeah yeah that's a great question and I
I am not a field biologist who who
studies strike Behavior but I I would
assume that they're doing some guarding
of the food because like like you said
uh otherwise it would seem like it's a
pretty easy target
um yeah I would add like a something
else interesting about their impalement
behavior uh is that it actually has
another function that's been observed in
some species of strikes and that is to
kind of leave food out until it's it's
better to eat because some of the
insects that they eat are poisonous
um but they can leave insects impaled on
on the thorn or a branch for a while and
you know the poison just kind of
degrades and becomes edible so yeah
there's got kind of lots of different
functions for for that kind of behavior
yeah
oh we got another question here who's
smarter parrots or corvids
that's a great question uh so I'll
preface by saying that I I do not study
bird cognition but yeah both both
corbetts and parrots are
incredibly cognitively complex groups
um and I would say like in terms of the
studies that have been done that I've
seen that compare their abilities
um
I would say
they are pretty equal like many of the
complex hard and disabilities that have
been seen in corvits have also been seen
in parrots and vice versa and in terms
of the size of their brains uh both of
them have among the largest uh brains
relative to body size of all the bird
groups
um and uh they do seem to have some
differences in their uh I guess
personality you could say like the the
ways in which they explore
um they they investigate things tends to
differ corvids tend to be a bit more
cautious uh than parents for example but
I think like in the end if you give like
a corvid and a parrot
um the same type of puzzle like they
might go about it in different ways but
in the end
um there's a pretty good chance that
both of them will be able to figure out
how to how to get fasted yeah
that's really neat I mean and that would
be an example of convergent evolution of
intelligence yes it is yep because yeah
we got that question here too some bird
species seem more intelligent than
others uh what evolutionary patterns are
there to intelligence in Birds
it does seem like uh intelligence is one
of these things that can run away pretty
quickly in social groups I mean we see
that with in humans for example you see
that this big runaway in in in our
specific lineage
um
we see that in Wales too it seems like
the uh that the toothed whales are
significantly more intelligent than
Baleen whales right
uh ten tens of your impressions but yeah
it is kind of hard to it's it's kind of
hard to say uh right
intelligence is one of these really
weird things where we we don't even
recognize it unless we can
train an animal really right and we
don't train like animals will only be
trainable if they care about us yeah the
obvious examples cats versus dog which
is smarter I mean the dog will do what
you say so it's easy to tell how smart
they are or what sorts of problems they
can solve right but the cat's just kind
of like uh I don't I don't care about
you you're right they might be way
smarter so it's
uh yeah living with so I I I had a
parrot so I lived with him for yeah
something like something eight or nine
years
um that was super interesting seeing his
intelligence I worked with birds of prey
and with uh crows at a wildlife rehab
center
and by far the crows were more
intelligent I mean that they would
figure out how to open their cage we had
we had injured animals we were trying to
rehabilitate them and so we would you
know we'd lock them in a cage when
they're injured and they're not safe to
leave yet but the the crows would
sometimes decide you know what I'm good
and they would just leave because we it
was hard to find a a way to to build an
enclosure that they couldn't escape from
they're just amazing as far as testing
everything for week the Velociraptor and
Jurassic Park yeah you're right
systematically testing for weaknesses
and then if you left if you didn't
actually put a padlock on something or
if you left it unlocked because you're
getting food and whatever they would
they would notice and they would Escape
by and large yet uh ultraviolet vision
is common to most birds yeah yeah
um excuse me I have someone at the door
can it go ahead
um I gotta go check the door real quick
but can you tell us about the Wonder
chicken well yeah all right
yeah I guess I'll
hello I'm back I'm back okay great yeah
yeah yeah I was waiting uh make sure you
didn't miss anything
um yeah so yes I can I can tell you
about the the Wonder chicken so
uh the Wonder chicken as is its nickname
um was the subject of another one of the
projects I worked on during my PhD
um
and so this was the the discovery of it
was was quite interesting
um so this was based on a fossil that
I've been collected in Belgium
um and had been sitting in a museum in
the Netherlands for you know
about a decade or so
um
but um my supervisor and one of my lab
mates was interested to look at it
um they were interested to to look at it
I should say uh because this was a
fossil uh dating to the very end of the
Cretaceous the very end of the age of
dinosaurs so it's uh it's just over 66
million years old which is the date when
the quotations ended
um yeah and who had collected it because
it was just a leg bone right sticking
out of a rock basically yes yeah yeah
yeah and had a paleontologist collected
it or was it someone in the public that
reported it or no it was it was a it was
a fossil uh collector I would have yeah
yeah uh I would have to look up look up
his name pardon me yeah let's see uh
foreign
and um it yeah it was a from from the
you know from the surface it didn't look
like much we there were a couple Bones
Exposed on the surface including a leg
bone uh it was enough that we could tell
there was a bird fossil in there yeah
but we didn't really expect anything big
to come out and we were just like well
uh no one else is studying this and we
studied birds and uh this is a bird this
is an ancient fossil bird so we might as
well look at it
um but uh what we did was that we
actually took the specimen uh to a CT
scanner and scanned it uh so we were
able to look inside uh the block of rock
without actually damaging the
potentially fragile fossil inside yeah
um and what we found was truly
extraordinary
um yes so yeah I actually might have a
have an image of the uh of what we found
on the on here can you see that yeah
that is amazing yeah yeah so this was
what we found after we scanned the
fossil and yeah like there was a lot of
swearing involved they were just
incredible so uh for those who might not
be aware that this is the nearly
complete skull of a bird and preserved
in pretty good condition uh for a fossil
word because as you probably know birds
have rather delicate skeletons and most
of the time you're not going to get
anything nearly as complete as this and
for a bird fossil
um yeah
and so we were extremely excited and not
only that but we could tell that this
was most likely uh not just any fossil
word but a member of the modern bird
radiation so this would have been a bird
that had all the features that we
associate with birds alive today
um for example having no teeth in the
Jaws that's a pretty big indicator yeah
um
and so we decided to yeah and this thing
lived alongside dinosaurs so that there
was um the
so this this pushed back some of the
traits to earlier than than we had had
yet in the fossil record right
yes uh somewhat um because the thing is
we had suspected before that modern type
Birds had originated in the late
Cretaceous
um uh but the fossils of them
from that age are very rare and before
this one we did have one other uh bird
fossil from the lake Cretaceous that
seemed to have been a modern bird uh and
that was a member of this group here uh
which is called the Davis it was found
in Antarctica it was also from about 66
million years ago
um but they gave this uh at least the
specimens that we knew at the time did
not preserve a skull so we did not know
what the skull look like
um but uh sorry Jordan has had a very
well preserved skull so yeah that did
indeed confirm that yeah a lot of these
modern bird traits were already present
in the Cretaceous and that this
particular lineage was was already
around uh back then yeah yeah
and yeah well it's just it's just really
neat to to know you know Birds evolved
from dinosaurs but they evolved from a
fairly a fairly old lineage of dinosaurs
so you actually had a
a big chunk of time where birds and
dinosaurs the things that you know like
modern-ish birds and dinosaurs were
living alongside of each other so it's a
it's really neat there's a lot of uh
really cool paleo art
yeah that I've probably started seeing
maybe 15 or so years ago where you they
were showing a lot of these you know the
birds alongside with their their uh
there dinosaur cousins yeah
uh yeah definitely and indeed uh my my
kind of role on this project was to do
sort of the follow genetic work and
figure out what kind of bird uh This was
um and so I I've drawn the Wonder
Chicken on this chart and it's over here
uh the actual scientific name that we
gave it was asterionis
um so there's there's a funny story
behind that name
um the name translates to asteria's bird
and so it's actually named after Asteria
the Greek
um uh titanus of falling stars
um and so that is the reference to of
course the end Cretaceous asteroid
impact that would happen after
asterionist lived it's not just that
actually because in Greek mythology
Asteria actually transforms into a quail
um and she jumps into the ocean
um and turns into an island to uh escape
from Zeus who is being Zeus as usual
um and uh since we we suspected that as
their urine is is actually closely
related to the chicken and duck lineage
which also includes quails so that was
also a an appropriate name in that
regard and it was found in Marine rocks
so it was found in the ocean
there are like multiple kind of meetings
there we are
um we're very happy with that name uh it
was kind of um the the person who came
up with it was our co-author Dan sepka
who is an expert in all kinds of fossil
Birds especially fossil Penguins
um and yeah it's pretty great but uh we
also like the nickname Wonder chicken
for it as well yeah
yeah
I I wonder chicken this is kind of like
a humble name yeah I like that I like
that Wonder chicken I mean it does it
does look fairly chicken-esque yes
and I mean yeah I remember
um when I first heard about it people
were saying that it's um it's got
sort of chicken-like and duck-like
features in the skull that's right I
don't know if you could even point out
what those are to to uh you know a leg
group but because I mean when I'm
looking at it I can't I can't tell which
yeah it's what I might be able to to
show you something yeah okay um yeah so
of course the the overall shape looks a
bit more more chickeny and the fact that
the the bones in the beak are not
closely fused to each other is more and
more chicken like uh you know in a duck
you look at a duck's call the bones of
the beak are like heavily fused to each
other and you can't really make out the
boundaries uh very well
um but it does does have some more ducky
traits as well in the skull so you can
see that the the tip of the peak is not
very hooked that's actually more more
similar to a duck lid than to a chicken
line a bird uh something else that's
stuck like is that the uh the top of the
skull has a sort of you can't make it
out very well in the image you have to
see it in 3D to make out better but
there's a sort of hourglass shaped
depression on the top of the skull which
is something we see in more duck-like
birds and not not so much in the
chicken-like ones so it's got a mixture
of traits uh from the both the chicken
like in duck-like lineages and that's
something very special because even
though we had before Wonder chicken very
strong evidence from especially from
genetics but also to an extent from
morphology as well that the chicken like
birds and the duck-like birds were close
relatives to each other
um we didn't really know what to expect
for what their common ancestor would
have looked like and that story the
order seems to be like the closest
approximation to to that
um because of course in the modern day
ducks and uh chicken-like birds are very
different from each other in terms of
overall appearance
but yeah sir Uranus seems to show that
their Common Sense most likely had a
mixture of uh both had traits from both
lineages
um
yeah so we we ran followed Jake analyzes
trying to take into account you know the
genetic evidence and the morphological
evidence as much as we could and uh what
we found was indeed that Australia
versus most likely an early member of
the branch leading to both the chickens
and Ducks now I will say uh that in some
of our analyzes we found that it could
also be an early member of the chicken
lineage and we can't really reject the
possibility it could be an early member
of the dark lineage
um but in the end that doesn't actually
matter a whole lot because that's kind
of what we would expect for something of
like a prototype kind of organism of the
sort is at the very earliest members of
any of these lineages are going to be
very very similar to each other so it's
not that surprising we can't really
narrow that down
um and so no matter where exactly it
falls uh probably a stereorus is the
closest that we get to like the
proto-duck chicken yeah
yeah that that is really cool now you
I've seen as I watched the video where
you know someone had the fossil in their
hands and it's just like a a cube of
rock basically with a leg bone sticking
out of it that's right and because you
you use the scanning Technologies to to
actually get the skull like for me it's
it would be so tempting to break that
thing open yeah so people have reframed
so far from breaking it open huh so far
I guess it's still in the Rock right now
yeah yeah yeah the thing is that the
rock is pretty hard and the bones are
are fragile so it would be very risky to
try and extract the Bones from the rock
yeah yeah I
but you know you just always want to
touch something you know yeah I I don't
think I'd have the discipline but you
want to have other you know future
generations with maybe better imaging
technology to be able to also study this
thing so yes that's good good good
willpower you guys have yeah yeah we
made 3D prints of the of the skulls
though so we kind of have like like
copies of them we can we can handle but
uh yeah
wow
the authors on that paper that
describing this uh what yeah what
exactly was all your I mean you
mentioned a little bit but yeah what
exactly was your involvement in that and
also how do you when you're doing a
group paper like this what's yeah what's
how's writing divided and how are I mean
how are tasks divided typically in your
group yeah yeah like that that's a great
question of course it varies from
Project to project
um but like in our particular case uh so
yeah let me let me think it was on the
paper so the first author was my
supervisor Daniel field and he he
basically led the project
um and organized you know most of the
the research
um the second author was my uh lab mate
Juan Benito uh who is working on like uh
describing this fossil
um for for his PhD thesis would
um which basically means that he was
going into detail with the the anatomy
and um and just kind of comparing it to
you know similar groups you know modern
groups that are alive today yeah um and
kind of just describing what the
features look like and how they compare
and he also did like the majority of the
work like actually Imaging The Falls
like visualizing the fossil because
after we had scanned it we had the scan
on a computer but we still had to
separate the Bones from The Rock like
within the computer
um and so we had to manually like kind
of separate those things out and oh my
laptop it did most of the work I did a
little bit Daniel did a little bit but
yeah on did the bulk of the word on on
that
um there was me I did the phylogenetic
work as as I mentioned earlier like the
analyzes and kind of selecting which
methods that we would use
um things like that and a little bit of
um just doing some comparative Anatomy
as well just comparing it to Modern
forms and seeing what kind of characters
we should look like
um uh John yuck is an expert in the
local geology where this fossil was
found
um and so he provided kind of the
environmental context
um in which uh this this fossil was
discovered so what kind of environment
uh did this fossil form and and
potentially what kind of environment
this animal lived in um so we think it
was a shoreline environment
um or it was preserved in the ocean but
there was a shoreline nearby
um and finally the last author on the
paper was a Dan SEPTA who I mentioned
earlier as well uh so he's an expert in
fossil birds in general and so so he he
knows a lot about bird anatomy and uh
bird Evolution
um and so he he was able to you know
give a lot of advice on
um the phylogenic analysis what tax that
we should look at and also use his own
knowledge to fill in some of the
knowledge gaps that we had in regards to
what features are found in what which
groups of birds
um and in terms of writing the paper so
the when you read the main text of the
paper most of that was drafted up by
Daniel
um by Daniel field because we have two
Daniels on our paper
yeah uh but like the thing about nature
papers is they tend to be very short the
name the main text part you have a very
limited amount of space to describe
things so the the main text of a nature
of paper is tends to be really just the
highlights for you which is like uh
here's what we found why is it important
and what what are the coolest things
about this discovery
um and Daniel wrote up most of that but
um if you look in the supplementary text
so most scientific papers have a
supplementary text which often goes into
more detail about things that they might
not have had room for in the paper and
for a nature paper that can be quite a
lot of things
um there there are we have many
different sections in the supplementary
texts and many of those were written by
by other people so I I wrote for example
the phylogenetics section in the
supplementary text it's going into all
the detail about
um uh what methods we use and what we
found in the phylogenetic analyzes and
what this means for understanding of
bird Evolution
um and all of this
um read over like all the texts that we
wrote and gave suggestions and comments
and edits um to of the text so yeah I
would say so each section of the text
had a main author but all of us had
input on all of the paper essentially
yep yeah yeah that's really cool I have
another question that came in from a
viewer about phylogenetics yep uh all
things considered as a lot of people say
birds are dinosaurs and this always
confuses me I understand they evolved
from dinosaurs but I was under the
assumption that dinosaurs refers to a
group of reptiles that died off so this
is I mean this is um this has been a
change in how we talk about organisms it
really is confusing also people say that
uh birds are reptiles which really I
mean you know that's that is just like
scientists messing with us right but but
so so talk about this kind of the shift
in in how we talk about
um families and finally genetics versus
you know the the older ways that we used
to talk about right you know animal
classification yeah yeah
um so yes that this is um
this is a bit a bit of a shift in uh in
kind of how we talk about groups of
animals
um so it used to be that
um
that we we would have a lot of them
uh the groups that animals are
classified into it needs to be and in
fact this kind of classification system
was established before we understood
Evolution so a lot of time
um ladeus or animals and other organisms
would just be grouped based on common
traits without any regard for The
evolutionary history of those traits and
so that's how we get things like uh the
reptiles our our own group but don't
include Birds even though photogenically
Birds fit within the reptiles uh because
the modern reptiles uh that aren't birds
like the lizards Turtles and
crocodilians they they all seem to be
more similar to each other from a
superficial perspective yeah compared to
birds or they're all cold blooded
they're covered in Scales they don't
have feathers
um
but uh in in recent years there has been
more of a well I'm getting ahead of
myself I should say that uh and even
after we understood Evolution
um
like this kind of classification system
was still very much in use
um so even after people understood that
oh well actually birds do evolved from
from reptiles and arms like a completely
separate group on their own people still
use the term reptile to mean uh like you
know the the scaly cold blooded members
of that lineage not including Birds
um
but in recent times there have been some
biologists who have uh kind of shifted
to a different system of using these
names
um and that is a system based on
phylogeny and so uh basically
the in this system all formal names
should apply to uh all the members of a
specific lineage to no exceptions and so
under this kind of phylogenetic
nomenclature is what we call it uh birds
can be considered a group of reptiles
because they evolve from reptiles and
what matters in terms of what makes your
reptile is not being cold-blooded or
being scaly but simply being a member of
that lineage and the way that we Define
these groups is based on phylogenetics
so for example people might say that a
reptile in phylogenetic nomenclature is
anything that's more closely related to
a lizard than to a human for example
um and under that definition then Birds
very much are reptiles
um so with with the
when it comes to dinosaurs it's a it's
an interesting case
um because I would say that
um dinosaurs scientifically speaking
have not have never necessarily been
defined by being extinct
um it's just that we didn't know that
birds were descended from dinosaurs for
for a long time uh the term dinosaur was
originally
um coined to refer to a specific group
of reptiles so in in that sense it
actually
um has a lot of you know it's actually
not that far off from kind of our
phylogenetic
um uh sense of the word
um
it's just that we did know that birds
were a member of that group
um but it it's had a bit of a there's
been a bit of a history to it though
because
after after the term dinosaur was
calling there was a period of time in
paleontology when it was thought that
um the so-called lizard-hipped dinosaurs
which very confusingly actually is the
lineage that includes Birds and the
so-called bird hit dinosaurs were
actually not that close to each other
and we're like completely separate
groups of reptiles and so during this
period people would say that oh well the
term dinosaur is actually a term for
these two different groups of reptiles
um it's just that they since they both
you know reach gigantic body sizes
during the Missouri blah blah blah uh we
we just call them the same thing but
then new research came in and we started
finding like very early dinosaurs and
also close relatives of dinosaurs and it
turns out it's more likely that actually
the bird hipped in Elizabeth dinosaurs
are a thing after all and that dinosaurs
do refer to like a distinct lineage of
reptiles by themselves and it was also
around this time that people started
kind of Reviving the idea that birds
evolved from dinosaurs and uh
over time shortly after this the
evidence are accumulating more and more
of course we
um the early fire genetic analysis that
were done on this problem uh that
analyzes that were done on this problem
um supported Birds uh as a lineage of
dinosaurs and um
uh and later on of course we got like
the fellow Ridge fossils
um so uh I and from from there on like
it was from a scientific perspective
like if we understand dinosaurs to be
like this distinct lineage uh referring
to a very specific group then it wasn't
a huge leap for us to say that oh well
actually since birds are also descended
from this lineage then they they should
also be considered a member of this
group
um but uh yeah it is true that in uh in
common musicians like in late late
people uh for for Lay people
um uh the term dinosaur has often been
associated with things that are extinct
and yeah so so I I can see how that is
that is confusing but but yes uh in by
like our modern understanding of bird
Evolution and also
um are currently preferred uh scientific
definitions of dinosaurs and indeed
birds are a type of dinosaur so
let me try and uh like put this in like
a single sentence
you've got yeah so in phylogenetics
everything's named in this hierarchical
hierarchical system so like humans are
we are Apes but we're also mammals so
it's you know it's you can call a human
a mammal or you can call a human a human
if you're calling a human a human you're
just being way more specific
um but we're also mammals and we're also
Apes
uh and we're also tetrapods because
we're we evolved from these uh
four-legged animals so we you know we're
we are tetrapods just like frogs or
tetrapods
uh so when we say that a bird is a
dinosaur that's the same as saying that
a human is a mammal uh essentially it's
you're just you're just being less
specific you're going back further in
time and and talking about the group
that uh birds are from
uh that was more than one sentence but
my attempt to some read this yeah no
that's good I've got a couple more
questions uh from the uh Stephen I see
yours I've got one we've got one from
Angie and
we're going to hit those a little bit
later but I wanted to just just
uh was there anything else before we
move on that you wanted to talk about
with the Wonder chicken and then I've
had a let's see what time is it here
oh yeah we've been talking for an hour
and a half now I guess well not not
quite but almost
um um yeah anything else about the
Wonder chick and then we want to talk
about uh like why how many bird lineages
survived the extinction and maybe why
they survived the extinction but but
before we do that just anything else
about this this beautiful Wonder chicken
well
um I would say like the the next topics
that I was that I was thinking of
covering are are the ones you you
mentioned actually and then well the
Wonder chicken is is related to them but
uh I think that's a pretty good segue
into into into those particular subjects
so uh do we want to do we want to head
on over there yeah like why did the
dinosaurs go these super awesome animals
uh
I mean there's just kind of this vague
idea that that a big animal is going to
be better at surviving than a small
animal but that's not what we see when
when we see this Extinction we see small
mammals surviving and we see small birds
surviving and all the big cool things
died why
yeah yeah
that's that's a that's a great question
um
and uh it is really interesting isn't it
so in general uh when we get big
catastrophic events uh large things tend
to die more readily and there are a
number of reasons for that uh one is
that large animals need more resources
in general so of course if there's a big
natural disaster that puts resources in
Jeopardy
um it's quite likely that large animals
won't be able to get enough to survive
um something else is that large animals
tend to grow and reproduce uh more
slowly or they say they reach adulthood
more and more slowly
um than smaller animals and so it's
possible that they are not able to
reproduce fast enough to replenish their
population in times of Crisis
um and there's there are also other
reasons too like large animals can't
take shelter as easily if there's a big
natural disaster
um and when it comes to the end
Cretaceous Extinction specifically we
have very strong evidence about the
cause of this Extinction and that is the
big asteroid impact
um in the Gulf of Mexico that happened
around then
um and the effects of this asteroid
impact uh would have been quite
devastating to many groups of animals
around the world and it was very
devastating
um
so of course the initial impact itself
would have caused a lot of damage uh but
it probably wasn't the main killing
agent that caused so many species to go
extinct at once uh probably uh some of
the more important factors of that
impact was not like the initial
explosion that happened when when
crashed into the Earth but the fact that
it uh threw so much debris into the
atmosphere
um and some of that debris would have
rained down
um at first and uh the debris that
rained down would have like
um
uh generated a lot of heat while it was
falling through the atmosphere and in
doing so it would have burned up a lot
of vegetation that it landed on it would
have burned up any animals that it
landed on and uh that certainly would
have killed off a lot more life like
pretty much all around the world and so
and a large animal living on land at the
time
would have been very unlikely to be able
to avoid that kind of verbal Firestorm
that happened
um
and after that even if they had made it
through uh there was still some more
debris that was left up in the uh in the
atmosphere and that uh all that dust and
certain that that would have basically
blocked out sunlight and it would have
caused a period of time when probably a
lot of the vegetation died out at least
the vegetation that hadn't already been
burned up earlier
um and which would have left like very
little kind of a you know uh food very
very few food resources left for for
animals to eat
um so large animals that would have
required a lot of food like even if they
hadn't died during the The Firestorm
earlier they'd very likely would have
starved to death during this time period
um
if you can't survive fire here's ice
yeah
um it would have been very very harsh
very harsh
um whereas small animals uh and I should
preface by saying that plenty of small
animals die during during this mass
extinction event they definitely weren't
immune to to these effects but
nonetheless they would have had a better
chance at least of surviving compared to
the big ones uh partly because well they
could they could hide from from that
Firestorm if they happen to be
underground in a Borough at the time
they were hidden in a rock crevice or or
a big tree or something that's possible
at the that the uh the the debris that
hit the the area outside them the heat
wouldn't have reached them um and they
they might have been able to make it
through
um they would have needed less food uh
and this is interesting because of
course
um birds today have very high
metabolisms and so they they do need to
eat a fair bit most of the time but even
so like the absolute amount of food that
a tiny bird needs is going to be less
than amount of food that's something
like a T-rex or Triceratops would have
eaten and so uh probably they were still
able to find food more easily
um and I think so a lot you got
barbecued dinosaur everywhere yeah
exactly yeah yeah right
um and also a lot of small animals are
able to go into a dormant State like a
lot of small mammals go into hibernation
for example
um during Harsh Times or they go through
what we call a torpor which is where
they just like uh lower their metabolism
to to like you know very very low levels
um and just kind of spend time as a semi
Ice Cube and and
sleep through uh kind of harsh
conditions
um right and do birds do that I I think
hummingbirds can do is something similar
right so it's not super common in Birds
but there are a few groups that can and
hummingbirds are one of them so
hummingbirds uh they need a lot of
energy to keep them afloat because
they're tiny and they're the tops and
they're so high and then so they're
during the day they're just constantly
feeding or like defending their their
food sources from other hummingbirds
um but of course uh during the night
time when they have to sleep uh they
they can't be constantly foraging so
they'll actually drop their body
temperature
um like to very very low
um levels and just kind of sleep and
sleep it through the night
um
and some of the um uh groups that are
closely related to hummingbirds um are
also able to undergo this uh this torpor
um as well
um so uh the groups like uh the uh the
swits and the night jars uh are also
groups of birds that are known to
undergo torper uh when you know the
conditions are amended go to that in
fact there are there's one species of
night jar that is considered the only uh
true hibernating bird that it doesn't
just undergo towards really through the
night but actually uh during the winter
time and sometimes like actually go goes
into the storm and state for several
days at a time
um so yeah it is unknown whether the
birds during the Age of Dinosaurs like
at the time of the mass extinction would
have exhibited this Behavior but uh
certainly for some groups of animals
that made it through that time it was
potentially a way they could have
survived
um that's really cool I never I never
even thought of that that was yeah
right
um I also say like being able to fly
must have I mean do we think that these
birds were flighted the ones that
survived yeah yep um so at least in the
modern group of birds uh like the modern
group of birds uh their last common
ancestor was almost certainly capable of
like there's essentially no no doubt for
about that so something like Astoria
even though we don't uh have its wing
bones preserved we assume that it was
probably a flighted uh bird
um and uh yeah like a flight probably
evolved like much further down the bird
vintage and increase our bird like but
you know not not quite modern Birds
um so by the time you get to True Modern
Birds uh these definitely would have
been capable of flights just like the
birds of today are and I I agree like
being able to fly probably would have
been a pretty big advantage in these
kinds of conditions uh because if you
don't have food in one area you could at
least like fly off and try to try to
find them somewhere else uh which is
definitely a lot more efficient way of
traveling than something I can only walk
so uh yeah that potentially was was a
was a way that helped birds survive that
mass extinction for sure
um so what's what's the consensus or I
guess may actually I'm pretty sure
there's not a consensus but how many
lineages do you think survived how many
years independent bird lineages survive
that group and and were able to leave
ancestors even today until today that's
right yeah yeah so that that is indeed a
big question in the studying the origins
of modern birds and it is very
controversial like when exactly did
these divergences happen so uh thanks to
asterionis and and they gave us we we
know that modern Birds did exist during
that end Cretaceous uh mass extinction
um and it's especially because of that
stereois we can infer that they have
split into at least three groups uh by
that time because that seriously belongs
to the chicken and duck lineage right so
we go with chicken dunklin each must
have existed then
um and because we know that we know that
their modern sister Group which is the
group called um Neo 80s must have also
existed then so this is a group that
includes all birds except the chickens
index and the ostrich lineage and
because
these two groups must have existed then
we know that their Collective system
lineage the the ostrich kind of uh and
Company lineage must have also diverged
at the time so at least these three must
have made it through
um but considering we haven't tricked
ourselves with uh yes convergent
evolution yeah yeah that's right yeah
assuming that we have the relationships
corrected I would say like among our
relationships
um within the modern bird group like
this is one of the best supported from
both genetics and morphology I would say
we are very confident about this
um
but the the question when it comes to
survivorship of modern Birds across the
kpg well Cretaceous poliogene mass
extinction kpg for sure
um
is so at least three made it through but
how many more might have made it through
and that that's a very controversial
question
um I would say like in terms of some of
the most likely lineages have made it do
it is possible that the chicken and duck
lineages might have already split them
um so I mentioned earlier that a
stereotypes might be an early member of
one of these too so so if it was then
clearly they had split by then and some
people think that they gave us is
probably a member of the duck lineage as
well and so
um if that's the case then these two
groups let's put it by then but the real
kind of the real controversy and the the
real difference uh like we're really
different with lie is like how many
members of neo-avs uh were present at
the expectations and this is a question
that has been extremely controversial
and I would say that we we are arguably
edging towards a consensus but we still
haven't achieved like uh a real one yet
and part the uh the reason for this is
because we don't have a lot of direct
evidence
um for members of this lineage during
the Cretaceous so we we don't have like
clear Cretaceous examples of any of the
members of new ladies being present so
if we did then we would have like we
would be able to infer like some other
lineages were around so so you've drawn
that because there's confusion here
whenever there's confusion on this tree
you drop you draw them all coming out
from the same point to illustrate that
that can exactly and so so that so the
the multiple branching pattern here is
uh is to reflect phylogenetic confusion
um because this tree is not drawn
against a geologic time scale so like
yeah I'm putting like groups from
different times like all over the tree
there's no there's no like uh uh Rhyme
or Reason like relative to time uh for
that the length of a branch is not
there's no information in that in your
business it's not indicating that this
is a longer more time has passed
exactly exactly
um so yeah Neo 80s has a lot of
controversies associated with it and one
of these is like how are all these
different major lineages related to each
other and on that there is like
basically zero consensus so I I drew
like uh how many like nine different
branches spouting from the same node
because we just do not know when it
comes to this node um yeah
but uh when it comes to the question
like how many of them were around uh by
the end of the quotations yeah that's
also a question where we don't really
know
um
but uh like you know how how do we
figure out like when they originally if
we don't have the fossils and so one of
the major ways that we do this is
through a method called the molecular
clock and a molecular clock in its very
simple terms is basically where you
compare the differences in genetic
sequences between different lineages and
then try to estimate how much time is
required to accumulate all those
differences
um and you can from there estimate like
when each of these pendages diverge from
each other but there are a lot of
complications to estimating uh these
Divergence times because we know that
genetic mutation does not stay at a
constant rate over time so you need to
be able to account for changes in rate
over time and and fixation depends on
yes selection and yeah right yeah
uh so it basically the results of your
molecular clock analysis Can Depend a
lot on assumptions that you put into the
analysis
um and so when you don't have direct
fossil evidence to go on uh you can get
very large error bars on a lot of these
estimates for the clock and so a lot of
the very early kind of um estimates of
when modern Birds diverge actually put a
lot of neo-adian divergences in the
Cretaceous so you you have people
talking about oh there were Cretaceous
uh like short birds and Penguins and
even parrots and things
um and a lot of those parts they are
were based on very controversial but
very incomplete uh fossils
um so a lot of those fossils are very
questionable whether they are actually
members of the modern bird group or not
or like members of Neo 80s or not
um I I seem to remember correct me if
I'm wrong or if this is essentially I
seem to remember a turtle
being confused for a parrot because that
was like a a part of the the turtle's um
uh face and it looked like a parrot beak
and it was actually someone someone
claimed it was a uh you know a parrot
living alongside dinosaurs at one time
right yeah yeah so so there's like this
this jaw of a peak animal that was found
in the Cretaceous
um and yeah it was interpreted as a
Cretaceous parent but uh like it's it's
just it's just a tip of a lower jaw and
as you know the lower jaw is used for
for processing food so uh like it could
it could belong to like some other kind
of beak animal quite easily and uh I I
don't think um uh it's necessarily been
interpreted as a turtle specifically but
some people for example have suggested
it might be uh an OV wrap Tauros or
which is a bird-like uh dinosaur that
also has a beak but it isn't a modern
bird
um yeah so so yeah like it's very
unclear whether that that really is a
parrot or not and indeed um more recent
kind of molecular clock estimates tend
to put most of the neo-adian radiation
after the Cretaceous and personally I
tend to think that is more plausible you
will find people who disagree so yeah
you go and ask some other person who
studies this and they might tell you
something completely different but
um I I tend to think like these reason
estimates that put most of the oeds
um primarily after the Cretaceous it uh
is more likely to be the case
um
and part of the reason for that is is
actually related to part of the reason
for why their phylogeny is so
controversial is that
it turns out that all these divergences
at the base of Neo 80s like no matter
what the follow genetic relationships
are probably happen in a very short
amount of time and we we have like very
good genetic evidence for this like all
the genetic you know phylogenies that we
come up with for Neo 80s and try to
scale It Against Time like these
branches are always very very very short
so clearly like they diversify from each
other in a very short period of time and
I think it's most possible that this
happened like right after Cretaceous
when there are a lot of empty niches and
they radiate it out like very quickly
um especially since we don't have like
clear fossils yeah in the Cretaceous
maybe it would be good to explain the
logic behind that why why is it that
after extinctions we see rapid
radiations of animals because this is
this is counterintuitive to a lot of
people so yep
so yeah after a big kind of catastrophic
event like a mass extinction uh you
would get like a majority of Life dying
out and then only a few survivors
remaining
um and what this does is that this kind
of releases of all the survivors from
constraints that have been there before
evolutionarily speaking because you know
before that there were loads of other
animals around or loads of other
organisms depending on what you're
talking about that
were occupying niches that potentially
these animals could have evolved into
but you know didn't at the time because
other animals were already doing those
things
um and so mass extinctions like
oftentimes remove so many of these
competitors that it gives room for the
survivors to very quickly evolve into
many many different forms
um like without constraint and just like
start occupying a lot of niches that
they weren't occupying before
um yeah there's another way to there's
another reason that this is helpful too
for getting Evolution to happen and that
is that uh
when like organisms will start to
specialize in a way of living and
they'll be competing with other members
of their own species really really
intensely and pretty much when you get
stuck on the top of what they call
what's called a fitness Peak so you're
when when a lineage gets really good at
surviving in a specific way
any slight deviation any slight mutation
that changes your morphology is going to
be detrimental it's going to make it so
you're less competitive with your uh
with those around you with with other
animals of your own of your own
population and so organisms get stuck on
these Fitness Peaks well after a major
Extinction kind of everybody sucks at
surviving
so there's NASA
you know well especially during the
catastrophe everyone's you know that
that all of that competition gets
relaxed
organisms can spread out they don't have
to be in direct competition so intensely
and so you can be not so good at a new
way of living but there's nobody who's
better than you and so you end up
evolving down that trajectory while some
other population evolves down a
different trajectory so yeah you get for
multiple reasons after an Extinction uh
there's just for the the sake of that
you've cleared out the competition but
also the uh
uh the competition of other large or
other animals other species you're no
longer competing with but you're also no
longer competing so strictly with your
own neighbors anymore other members of
your own species so you have this
relaxation of natural selection
right after an Extinction event uh
so that you can actually have some some
wiggle room larger mutations can be
selected for than would otherwise be
acceptable by natural selection
um sorry did I cut you off with oh no
I'm not really
um so yeah I was simply talking about
like uh just having you know very very
short branches in neo-avian
um Evolution and why why I suspect that
might relate to like a post-radiation
um uh extinct um yeah post Extinction
radiation event
um
so so yeah that's that's kind of where
the state of where things are right now
but it would help if we can get like you
know the earliest neo-avian fossils or
something uh to help us constrain those
dates down uh further
um but yeah it is a it is a very
controversial uh topic yeah okay I've
got a couple questions that maybe we'll
try and do uh real quickly because I
want to be you know consider your time
here uh
f and then and then one that might be a
little bit longer that I have it'll let
me just throw this at you real quick so
that you can think how how deep you want
to go into this okay uh before I do some
of the um the uh the group questions but
I am curious about how
scientific consensus works in your field
because I know that there still are a
couple of dudes hanging on to this birds
are not dinosaurs idea
um yeah yeah uh but it's I think it's
like there's maybe two researchers that
are holding on to very publicly
um so it'd be fun to talk about that for
for you know however long you want but
before that let's let's get to some some
uh group questions here
let me scroll back up here to Steven
um
bird language is interesting to me as an
observer of birds and bird Behavior what
discoveries have there been about the
evolution of bird calls or hearing in
Birds slash dinosaurs oh wow that is
that is a really great question and
unfortunately uh from a paleontological
perspective uh the answer is not a whole
lot and the main reason for that is
because uh the main organs used to make
sounds uh in birds are generally not
preserved in the fossil record so they
are they are soft tissue structures
um so they they usually aren't aren't
preserved uh so yeah we don't know too
much about the sequence of how I would
say something like like a parrot gets
it's very complex kind of vocalizations
um however uh there is a pretty notable
fossil find
um of an end Cretaceous modern type
version that's the vagavis that I
mentioned earlier uh they gave this is
actually the oldest known bird that
preserves what we series which is the
vocal organ of birds
um and in because in some birds even
though I said it's a soft tissue
structure it's a in some birds it's made
of like harder materials than others and
yeah so it it um in one specimen of the
Davis it actually preserves uh the
Searing structure which shows that
modern type Birds had this organ in in
the Cretaceous
um it's a very different organ than the
one that we use right it's down in the
lungs right or yeah it's basically where
the uh the windpipe branches out into
into the two lungs and it's situated at
that Junction there
um they actually have so because it's
because it's after the the lungs split
in two yeah there's the pipe splits in
two they they have two um different
vibrations that they get to play with
which gives them a lot more versatility
than we have yeah yeah so so yeah a lot
of songbirds can like basically sing two
songs at once which is pretty wild yeah
yeah
um but yeah unfortunately like other
than telling us that the the series is
there uh we we can't really determine
much about uh like what kind of calls it
would have made just from like the
preserved material
um so yeah so unfortunately the answer
is that we don't know a whole lot about
uh the origin of bird vocalizations from
the fossil record uh but there there are
a few tantalizing hints there yeah in
Jurassic Park two is that where is that
where he has the Velociraptor voice box
and he's blowing through it yeah yeah
that's um that was three I think but but
yes okay
uh yeah yeah yeah so so that yeah that
doesn't really happen for me it doesn't
actually work yeah right right there is
some there is one group of uh non-verse
dinosaurs where people have kind of done
that with a plausible basis and that is
the duckbill dinosaurs
um a lot of those have like these really
long crests that actually connect to
their nasal cavity so like their
nostrils go in and they go run through a
series of tubes in the crest before
going into the lungs and it is
speculated that this might have been a
vocal kind of amplifying structure and
so people have tried to like model what
kind of sounds might have been created
by the structure but oh that's most
animals yeah yeah but but most animals
are you know including birds don't have
bony kind of vocal organ so that can't
really be done so so sadly yeah well I I
guess the with the with the duckbill
dinosaurs there you could get
what you could see from that is is if
you understood the material that the
structure was made of and the shape of
it the size of it you could get the um
the harmonics out of it but that
wouldn't that wouldn't tell you anything
about the clicks or that you like the
exactly the the different that would
just tell you what harmonics get
magnified by that structure but but not
what's nothing about the sequence of
noises that's going in yeah
let's see we've got
that's really cool that's that is a
really cool topic great question by the
way Stephen yeah let's see
uh birds or dinosaurs as Angie asks did
you talk about theories of behavior
example did the larger dinosaurs flock
can you tell if they took care of their
young or did they just lay eggs and
leave Etc right yeah that's a really
excellent question it certainly a
behavior is something that we're always
interested in teasing out from the
fossil record but it's also very
difficult to study because we can't
actually study living examples of these
animals and observe their behavior
um but yeah like whether or not the
number dinosaurs uh where social and
took care of the young that that's a
that's definitely something that we have
some insight on and uh
uh the short answer is that uh probably
different groups of dinosaurs did things
in different ways which is kind of what
do you expect because these behaviors
are very variable in modern animals too
um
however uh I would say yeah we had
pretty decent evidence that a lot of
um non-brew dinosaurs uh probably hung
around in groups like we often find uh
examples of where a lot of different uh
individuals of the same species were uh
buried together at the same time in the
same place and of course that doesn't
necessarily mean they were social but we
have many examples of these uh and uh it
would seem that it is plausible that at
least some of them were social groups
um and we also have track ways of like
multiple individual
um you know dinosaurs traveling
alongside each other uh things like that
um in terms of whether or not they took
care of their young that's a that's also
a really great question
um and so
our default assumption actually would be
that most uh dinosaurs probably did take
care of their young and the reason for
that is because
um well not only because modern birds
take care of their young but also
because the closest living relatives of
birds the crocodilians also take care of
their young after they hatch yeah
um yeah so because
um these two groups of animals um that
kind of uh what we call it what we say
phylogenetically bracket the number
dinosaurs in between
um mainly that they are the closest
living relatives and the number
dinosaurs both take care of their young
we we think that this is probably this
might be a trait that originated in the
last common ancestor of birds and
crocodilians that would have been
inherited by most of the non-verse
dinosaurs too
um so our default assumption is indeed
that they probably would have but
whether we have any direct evidence for
that Yeah we actually do so uh again the
um the duck though dinosaurs are a major
example of this um we have like nesting
grounds
um of like doctor dinosaurs where they
gathered together in big groups to lay
their eggs and the we also have like
babies preserved in those nests and we
can tell that those babies probably stay
in the nest for a little while and so
presumably we're being guarded and taken
care of by the adults for some time
um and in an example uh where it's more
closely related to birds in some of the
very bird-like dinosaurs like the
oviraptorosaurus like these are
dinosaurs with feathers
um and very similar to Modern Birds uh
and even though they could not fly we
actually have examples of these
dinosaurs preserved on top of their
nests so they're actually sitting on top
of their eggs and probably to incubate
them like much like a modern bird would
um so that's another example where
there's we have evidence of Parental
care in these Mesozoic dinosaurs however
we also have evidence that some Mesozoic
dinosaurs probably didn't take a whole
lot of care of their young in many of
the large sauropod dinosaurs a big
long-necked plant-eating ones
um it seems that uh they most likely
just just laid their eggs and left um
because The Land Before Time lied to us
yeah unfortunately yes sir we we have um
we have fossils of eggs and embryos of
these dinosaurs too and it seems that
the young were pretty self-sufficient
um and plus because the young were so
much smaller than the parents uh it
probably would not have been practical
even for for the parents to interact
much with them
um oh yeah so yeah so uh so it it is
thought that most of the sauropod
dinosaurs probably weren't just weren't
such great parents um but it many of the
other dinosaur groups it seems that they
most likely did take care of their young
for at least a short time period
um so that yeah that's quite interesting
isn't it yeah just imagining a little
baby sauropod and how amazing that would
be as a pet yeah yeah
until it starts growing oh yeah I grew
fast yeah uh okay I I have a question
sorry this one action might be pretty
intense to try and go over so but the a
lot of these feathered dinosaurs early
on that have they have like little Proto
Wings yeah
and there's a lot of them there's a lot
of yeah so you got the the over of a
Raptors yep
do we think they're secondary do you
think that they'll they had been
flighted and lost flight or do we think
that this I mean like why would they
have why would there be so many species
with feathered wings that are not flying
exactly yeah that's a that's a that's an
excellent question and it is something
that has been debated uh among the
researchers who study these dinosaurs
um so yeah like we we see like these
wing-like structures and you know we've
had Torah stores we see them in
germanosaurids which is a group that
includes a velociraptor and it's kin um
we know they have flight like feathers
on their arms yeah yeah like they have
like feathers very similar to Modern
birds and they formed basically big
wing-like structures on their forums
um like we have the direct fossil
evidence of this and so yeah the
question is like yeah why did they have
wings uh if many of these were not
flying uh dinosaurs now we actually know
of a few German swords like they're all
some of the smaller ones that were
likely able uh to move through the air
to some extent like uh whether that's
colliding or some kind of limited
powered fight that is debated
um
but they there there were some that
seemed to have been able to fly however
uh whether or not they all descended
from a flying ancestor is something
that's somewhat controversial uh some
some researchers have said that yeah
probably probably there they were
um however it's complicated because the
thing is we don't have any fossils of
like these potential flying ancestors of
these groups
um like if we try to reconstruct their
their phylogenies like we don't see like
an early like flying Branch coming out
here where where that could have led to
the Oviedo resource for example
um and like even with like having some
of the flying jeromeosaurus like those
seem to be like fairly isolated lineages
like it doesn't seem like this is a uh
something that's ancestral to the whole
group and so the majority consensus at
the moment is actually that uh Wings
evolved before flight
um and that these dinosaurs were using
their wings for for other reasons which
I'll I'll try to get you in a moment but
I would say that even though this is the
current consensus I I am not so ready to
discard the possibility that these could
be secondarily fightless animals because
yeah yeah we know in the modern day
birds can lose their fight all the time
and that can cause a lot of confusion
when it comes to the phylogenetics there
so yeah I think it is still possible
that they they might be but there isn't
a much direct evidence for it
um so I mean obviously there's lots of
uses for feathers But Wings specifically
it's why it seems so weird to me like a
wing specifically especially with with
wing feathers that are so well developed
that they actually leave Impressions on
Bones exactly it seems like that is like
why what other use is there aside from
lighting for wings right yeah so they're
in multiple hypotheses I've been put
forth for what the function of the
earliest Wings might have been before
they were used for fight and uh you know
you could take these as you will I would
say most of them are at least plausible
and it's possible like multiple of them
were at play
um as a selective pressures so one of
them is discrete because we know the
earliest feathers were a sort of hair
like coding that kind of just code you
know kind of covered the body so
probably primarily for insulation
um but uh if you have a wing if you have
these broad feathers uh structures then
you have a bigger surface area with
which you can display with so you can
have all these interesting color
patterns and bright colors on them so
that's one possibility that they were
having wings it's more useful for as a
visual kind of display structure or
communication
um another one actually relates to the
nesting behavior that I mentioned
earlier we have a lot of these dinosaurs
um sitting on the nest using their own
body heat to incubate their eggs like a
modern bird would and probably having
these Wings would allow the dinosaurs to
be able to actually cover up their eggs
more efficiently like a blanket
um compared to if they didn't have have
the wings in the first place
um so that that's another suggestion
that I've made for the original function
of the wings
um and finally uh wings that are not
used for flight uh can still be used in
Locomotion and even if they're not used
for any kind of like aerial Locomotion
like not even for gliding
um because for example we see in the
modern day that something like an
ostrich an ostrich
um even though it can't fly at all with
with its wings it will use its wings as
sort of Rudders or like balancing organs
while it's running like it'll stretch
out his wings while it's running to keep
its balance or to make tight turns and
so this definitely would have been
something that would have been very
useful to a lot of these small dinosaurs
um and there are also other methods of
locomotion using the wings that that
aren't flight so uh one that it's gained
some traction is called a wing assisted
incline running yeah it's when a bird uh
runs up a slope while flapping its wings
and the wings like literally help it
gain traction so I guess I was an
unintentional pun earlier
um while it's running up the slope so uh
like some birds that have very well
developed wings
um can actually like run up a vertical
surface just by flapping like without
flying uh just they can run up a
vertical surface by with the help of
wing flapping
um and as far as we know like the
flapping apparatus in these early winged
dinosaurs was not as well developed as
it was in modern birds so maybe they
weren't as good as at this kind of
behavior but even being able to do
something like a little bit at a time
where nothing else could do it is is a
potential Advantage
um so yeah there are like a lot of
interesting behaviors birds do with
their wings so I mentioned like the uh
balance and engaging traction there's
also like helping your you write
yourself if you if you take a fall like
a lot of baby birds that can't fly it if
you throw them off a high a high surface
thing if you do that sort of thing I I
hope you provide padding at the bottom
but yeah they're pretty light so they
can probably take a pretty pretty strong
fall
um but uh they will actually like
stretch out their wings and like
reorient themselves so they land on
their feet
um yeah yeah so there's all kinds of
ways in which Wings can help birds
maneuver like even without being
involved in actual flying
yeah
um I'm trying to think if there's
another uh let's see
user question
oh here's here's here's one other good
one and then then we'll talk about the
um the uh like John Rubin and Ellen
fiducio yeah sure but okay so
are there poisonous birds or venomous
Birds uh-huh yeah that's a really good
question
um so there are no known venomous Birds
but there are a few poisonous ones and
and just people people know Venom is
Venom is injected so like snakes have
venom and then poison is like if a
predator eats you he gets poisoned so
that's right that's a difference there
yeah yeah right
yeah so the the classic kind of uh
saying is that if it bites you when you
die then it's venomous and if you bite
it and you die it's poisonous
um so uh yeah there are a few poisonous
Birds um especially especially
um some of the songbirds um so yeah
there are a few different uh groups of
songbirds that have evolved uh the
ability to sequester toxins in their
feathers and their flesh
um they're not producing the toxins
they're they're sequestering them from
food right it's from their food yes yeah
so so they it seems that they mostly
feed on like poisonous arthropods and
then they accumulate these poisons in
their body and it ends up in their in
their feathers and and their skin
um and so let's see so one of these is
uh this species uh it's a Genus ifrita
the common name is a fleet or blue
captive wheat
um and it's a it's a small uh bird that
likes to climb on tree trunks in New
Guinea uh and it's one of these
songbirds that is able to like sequester
uh poisons in its body
um and they're they're like for example
some members of the Afro Eurasian Oreo
group and some members of The Whistler
Whistler group these are all um uh the
poisonous members of these groups all
tend to live in New Guinea or like
Australia
um which is kind of odd I don't think we
know why why what it is about those
places that cause them to tend to evolve
poison
um yeah but uh that it it is the case
and um
so far we don't have a lot of field
observations about how this poison is
actually used but experiments like where
people have like uh tried to you know
give offer these feathers to a snake for
example that by trying to eat these
birds in their natural habitat have
shown that the birds don't really know
not not the snakes don't really like the
fear of the the those toxins so probably
it has a function in Predator defense uh
people I've also suggested that it might
keep parasites away as well so yeah so
short answer is yes sir there are a few
poisonous birds and those are just a few
examples it also might just be a way I
mean they're they're excreting the
toxins so it's not in their body right
they're putting it yeah it could be like
a side effect yeah yeah you have um
there's so I had a comment here Venom is
a type of poison though
there's a typo there but I think that's
what that's what he's saying um yeah
yeah there actually are some Venoms that
are not poisonous uh so like a lot of
snake Venoms for example if you were to
just drink them I don't recommend it
because if you have any sort of lesion
inside your yeah digestive system you
will die but they're they're not
poisonous and the reason for that is
that the snake has it's actually it's
saliva and the snake is swallowing it
all the time uh uh so they're they've
these are these are toxins that have
evolved to be highly potent in the
bloodstream but the you know
especially snake stomachs but even a lot
of mammal stomachs can can handle them
just fine so you'll have birds that uh
you know they'll remove Venom sacks when
they kill a snake
and it's not it's not very dangerous for
them it's so long as they don't get bit
because swallowing a little bit of that
Venom was actually not toxic
um at low levels so yeah that's a really
interesting difference between poisons
and Venoms is that that that can be
possible where a Venom might not
actually be poisonous if swallowed
we got a late Comer asking a question I
just joined so if there's been a
so if this has been answered forgive the
and ignore can you discuss the
evolutionary path that led to the air
sacs that allow such amazing respiration
abilities and yeah let's do that real
quick because we do want to get to the
um yeah the birds are not dinosaurs
claim so yeah yeah okay so it's a really
really quick yeah yeah so so a bird's
lungs are very unlike ours
um our lungs are basically you know just
these yeah the air goes in our lungs
inflate and when we breathe out our
lungs kind of uh shrink uh so they're
like balloons basically and they just
inflate and deflate
um uh as we breathe in and out but in
Birds the lungs do not inflate and
deflate by themselves
um instead they are connected to a
series of air sacs that are distributed
throughout the body
um and the air sacs are the structures
that inflate and deflate as the uh the
air moves through the respiratory system
system and so they're kind of like
Bellows that pump the uh the air through
the lungs
um and because of the way that these air
sacs are arranged
um when an air when a bird breed is in
some of the air enters its lungs but
some of it also goes into the air sacs
first
um and so uh when the bird breathes out
the air from the air sacs actually goes
into the lungs and in this way a bird
actually gets fresh air no matter if
it's breathing in or out and in that way
they actually have a much more efficient
respiratory system than we do
um so yeah is it more if you count all
the air sacs though is it really more
efficient is it more efficient in volume
or is it more efficient in that it's
constantly supplying the blood with it
with air it's more efficient in the
sense that it's it's constantly
supplying right and the and to be clear
like the air sacs themselves do not
absorb like any of the oxygen they don't
do any gas exchange the the actual gas
exchange happens in in the lungs so the
the the the air sacs are just like the
where the air passes through like wow
wow it's on the way or out
um and and there must be a little bit of
gas exchange there but but yeah yeah
yeah
um right so uh yeah do we have any
evidence of the air sac system uh in
like non-verse dinosaurs and uh the
short answer is yes
um because uh this is actually one of
the main reasons that birds have hollow
bones so people often assume that birds
are power bones for flight but actually
the hollow spaces in their bones are
like the spaces where they're air sacred
or extensions of their attacks actually
fit into so like their respiratory
system literally invades the bones
they're their skeleton which is very
very interesting
um and so in a lot of the number
dinosaurs including uh you know most of
the B teaming Dinosaurs the theropods
um which include birds and also in the
long neck uh sauropodomorph dinosaurs uh
we actually have evidence that they had
air sacs because they have hollow
Chambers in their bones like birds do
um
so we know that the bird-like
respiratory system probably originated
at least
um like in the last common ancestor of
the theropods and sauropodomorphs but
the question is how far back it goes and
for that we don't have as much direct
evidence
um like we don't have um you know these
Hollow Chambers in the bones of bird hip
dinosaurs however uh you can have air
sacs without them invading the bones
themselves
so like that doesn't demonstrate that
they didn't have air sacs
um so yeah we we don't really know on
that front like how far back the air
attacks actually go but we do know that
by the time we have a sauropodomorphs
and theropod dinosaurs that here sacks
were present
[Music]
I just had my audio cut out can you hear
me oh uh I can hear you now okay okay so
uh
the
I sorry nothing another tiny morning
doves when they fly they'll like chirp
at every flap is that yeah is that their
air sacs pushing that as they're flying
or is that just something that they're
doing they're vocalizing oh no so so
it's actually neither of those so oh wow
that is that is the sound that they make
with their feathers themselves so that
yeah that's a that's a really
fascinating thing about some birds and a
lot of members of the the pigeon group
do this
um is that they they actually have make
distinctive sounds with their wing
fillers and like that can serve all
kinds of functions like some birds use
that in courtship some birds use that as
a warning signal and yeah so basically
vocalizing is not the only way birds
make distinct noises it's pretty cool
yeah that's neat all right so getting to
the so John Rubin I actually know John
Rubin because I used to live in
Corvallis Oregon and he lived like 20
minutes away or maybe he's like five
minutes away from me wait we went out to
Coffee once I think and and um we talked
about this and he's he's one of these
guys who's really
um
like he has not let go of the idea
it's been years since I talked to him
but yeah when I talked to him he was
still fighting hard for the birds
dinosaurs concept and then the other guy
who's who's uh you know well established
who also argues for this is Ellen
fiducia that's right and they
um I mean John Rubin
he's he told me I mean
he he definitely is a sincere believer
but he also says that he he also feels
like his his responsibility to just keep
on hammering it down as as Devil's
Advocate too so right he has both of
those things going on but he he really
is he he seems to be a True Believer or
maybe someone who got stuck in an
argument and can't get over it yeah but
uh yeah if you can just go over that the
birds are not dinosaurs argument and and
why nobody believes that anymore except
for these two guys would be yeah yeah
yeah it's uh it's a it's an interesting
thing right I mean like the the origin
of birds has been a controversial topic
for you know as long as people have
known about birds and evolution and and
uh because modern birds are just so
distinct from all other living things
that it has been quite you know
fascinating to think about how how did
they get all these distinctive features
in the first place
um and of course early on like through
comparative Anatomy people who did
figure out that yeah Birds evolved from
reptiles uh but after that the question
was like what kind of reptile they
evolved from yeah um and so there are
all kinds of different competing ideas
during this time uh but eventually uh
well I like I would say like even very
early on there were people who suspected
that birds were at least closely related
to dinosaurs and certainly if you look
at the skeletons of like you know all
these small meat-eating dinosaurs they
they do look more bird-like than pretty
much any other organism can be
um
but yeah like uh back then we only knew
a few species of of these these early
dinosaurs these small dinosaurs like we
um uh didn't know as much about like the
the bird like features that they they
might have especially soft tissue
features like feathers um so it was
still very controversial and it did
didn't really take off that much
um and especially
um there was a there was a book written
on the origin of birds
um which was I think it was called the
origin of birds and
um by Alan fiduciary yeah right so it
was not actually by Alan feduccio it's
by um uh okay I I'm probably gonna say
his name wrong but I
Gerard heilman
um and uh so this was a this was a um
book that came out like oh I don't know
um let's see the origin of birds uh it's
it originally came out uh as a as a book
in in English in 1926 and uh Powerman
was like a very he was he was primarily
an artist but he he was also a very like
uh dedicated kind of comparative
anatomist and so he did all these
comparative Anatomy studies comparing
Birds to to non-bird dinosaurs and all
other kinds of reptiles and he did point
out that oh well there are all these
different
um uh features that uh clearly uh Birds
only share with Dinosaurs however I
don't actually think they evolved from
dinosaurs because he thought that
non-verb dinosaurs did not have a
wishbone
um yeah which turned out to be an error
because as it turns out that we Now
understand uh that actually a lot of
non-verse theropod dinosaurs had
wishbones in fact we think most of them
did
um and but the problem is the wishbone
is just like it's such a small bone that
sometimes it's misidentified or
something not preserved in fossils and
so a lot of the time like previous
examples that we had were overlooked but
over time we eventually did find that
they did have wishbones and uh not only
that but uh then in the 19
1969 John Ostrom the paleontologist
um named the dinosaur Deinonychus and he
started doing like a series of like
detailed studies like comparing
dynamicus
um tier skeletal structure of birds
including early birds like archeopteryx
and he found that you know bone for bone
Anonymous even though it's much bigger
than archeopteryx was basically uh you
know at a first order approximation
almost identical in skeletal structure
hierarchy afterwards and that kind of
started the the Resurgence of like the
birds our dinosaurs idea yeah sorry what
species was that again it was oh uh
dynamicus it's a it's basically a
dromosaurian it's a larger relative of a
Velociraptor yeah and it's the one that
the the Velociraptor in the movies is
actually based that's right yeah exactly
yeah yeah so
um that okay so John Rubin
his argument and I'm sorry if John Rubin
happens to be listening to this and I
get this wrong but this was I mean when
we were having coffee together several
years ago he was explaining that he
thinks that uh like the Velociraptor and
all those that they are flightless birds
right
um so instead of birds evolving from
dinosaurs those dinosaurs are flightless
birds so and and he thinks that he
thinks that birds evolved from a
crocodile relative right so I mean it's
kind of funny because creationists use
this as an argument against Evolution
like oh look these scientists can't
don't agree on anything but even even
the the birds not dinosaurs scientists
they think that
Birds evolved from a close relative to
dinosaurs they just they put the split
earlier yeah than than everybody else
does
and the relationships even you know with
Velociraptor and so on they they
consider Velociraptor to be
um related to birds just like other
biologists do it's just uh yeah so yeah
so so that that's a that's a um
that's a really interesting kind of
development uh because the early
arguments of the birds are not dinosaurs
people uh we're very different actually
from yeah yeah yeah so so yeah so like
like I was saying right so with John
Ostrom studies in the you know mostly in
the 1970s onward
um and there's there's hard to be a
Resurgence in the idea that further or
dinosaurs like despite the the first the
wishbone mixed up um from earlier in the
20 20th century
um
uh so more and more people started to
you know uh
look favorably upon upon birds being
descended from dinosaurs and uh later on
in the 1980s we got like some of the
earliest phylogenetic analyzes like
actually trying to investigate this
question
um and they also supported birds being
nested within dinosaurs uh but of course
there was pushback and so that's where
the kind of birds are not dinosaurs
group came in yeah um and so uh mostly
these researchers were ornithologists so
they were they were experts in uh modern
type Birds but not necessarily experts
in non-verb dinosaurs
um and so a lot of their arguments uh
mostly centered around uh well they
couldn't see how like a uh
a ground-dwelling dinosaur could evolve
into a bird for example um and they
would they would try to pick out
features that um they suggested that
could not have transitioned from the
dinosaur condition to the bird condition
um uh things like that yeah that's what
that's what John rubin's earlier
arguments were
um yeah so yeah he's his his current
he's kind of like restructured his whole
view but also in a way that he could
keep his yes foundations yeah yes
um so so they made all these arguments
and there was certainly heated debate
for a while uh but the thing was like a
lot of those arguments were often either
based on misinterpretations of fossils
so that this the features they said were
present in dinosaurs were actually not
present or uh it turned out that uh we
actually do we actually can figure out a
transitional had a stage for for some of
these uh features like through embryonic
development or or actually finding
fossils that show transitional stages uh
in in these in in the evolution of birds
um and so like one by one like all of
their arguments were pretty much like
dismissed and uh like over over time
like Father genetic analyzes are very
consistent in finding birds as dinosaurs
like no matter what species you include
like who runs the analysis
um and like more and more dinosaur
fossils were being found showing like
features
um that are otherwise only found in
birds and
um and in many cases actually showing
what early stages of the evolution of
these features might have been like and
of course eventually we get like the
actual feathered dinosaurs like uh
non-bird dinosaurs preserved with
feathers which was sort of a Smoking Gun
um because otherwise we don't find
feathers in any other group of animals
um but from there on like the birds are
dinosaur dinosaurs people kind of
changed changed their teared a little
bit not not that not that they accepted
that birds were dinosaurs but instead
they say that oh well now that you've
found like modern feathers on all these
dinosaurs clearly these are not actually
dinosaurs which is what you were talking
about earlier uh clearly these are early
birds instead and so they just kind of
kind of flipped that script around
um
even though like uh just just like less
than a decade ago they were saying that
there's no way like the Velociraptor was
closely related to birds based on its
collegial structure of things like that
um so yeah that's kind of how how their
argument has evolved but again like it
they're they're kind of just like moving
the goal posts a bit because the
features that you
that they're saying like could could not
have you know given rise to like all
these modern feather dinosaurs uh like
dinosaurs and modern feathers I should
say is that's confusing
um like you they run they run into the
same problems as the arguments saying
that oh these bird features could not
have evolved from dinosaurs because we
we find the Transitions and the that we
don't have any better candidates for
um you know bird ancestors in the fossil
record yeah
um and at this point like like you
mentioned earlier there are probably
only like two people in in the world who
both like study bird Origins
professionally and and do not accept uh
birds being dinosaurs so uh it is very
much safe to say that birds being
descended from dinosaurs is the
mainstream View at this point and that
there is essentially
um I would say like no debate about this
uh from a scientific standpoint anymore
yeah yeah and I mean my my interaction
with John Rubin he seemed like the kind
of guy that uh if he was convinced he
would just kind of stop talking about it
rather than yeah publicly apologize or
like a bit confused but yeah he's an
interesting guy
um but
yeah there's always characters like this
in science and it's oh man it's been
really interesting to see this in uh
with kovid again real time
um
because there's always characters like
this in science that uh they're
convinced of an idea and when new
evidence comes in they don't want to
accept it
and
it's I mean it's just part of being
human right yeah and it's it is hard it
is hard to um
to keep yourself in check so that it
doesn't happen and it's yeah it's been
it's been tragic to see this happen with
things that are you know causing deaths
and so on like people yeah people I you
know
I one of my colleagues was anti-vaccine
early on and when more and more evidence
came out that the vaccine was safe he
actually doubled down
um but anyways the the uh
yeah the conflicts in science are always
really interesting we we had this
careful documentation of observations on
one hand and then the ongoing argument
about what those observations might mean
and you can actually come to very
different conclusions on things and
people can go to their graves with uh
these little feuds that are going on in
science but
the field in general will correct itself
as time goes on and these arguments are
part of that process it's part of the
how the sausage is made you know yeah
indeed
uh well I there are a couple more little
questions I apologize to anyone I mean a
lot of it's a lot of them are coming
from people that we did answer quite a
few questions from the from them as well
so hopefully you will forgive us for uh
ending here now I just I thank you so
much for coming on this was a wonderful
conversation my pleasure this poster is
great this poster is for sale I'm gonna
put a link to that in the video
description for people so they know
where to get it I've got a huge one on
my wall you got to get a pretty big one
because it's it's a huge there's a lot
of content on it
um
and uh yeah I love it it's I stared it
all the time I've gotta actually right
across from my desk so I can look at it
when I'm working
um I just just kind of uh Ponder some of
these little little questions here and I
really like how transparent you are and
and showing the uh
you know when there's confusion you have
multiple
languages branching from a single point
it's it's very it's really neat to see
that there's a lot of information impact
yeah
well everyone so long for now I'm gonna
be doing these every week until
Christmas and Christmas I leave for
Ecuador I'm gonna be there for a couple
of weeks and then yeah we'll yeah but
yeah we'll be doing Sunday morning
science until then so stay tuned and
make sure to give us a like if you liked
it and uh you you know you can always
send a Super Chat as well if you'd like
but uh until next week
stay curious